one of the questions that I get asked
the most on this channel is how do you
program realistic sounding guitars with
midi instruments and it's a question
that I always kind of Dodge because I
grew up playing guitar and I have a
bunch of guitars in my studio so
typically if I need guitar on a song
I'll either play it or I'll hire out a
session guitarist because I don't know
it's one of those things where I always
like the live thing if I have that
however I understand that some people
don't have access to a guitar some
people don't have the money to purchase
a guitar some people don't know how to
play a guitar and so I wanted to make a
video where I kind of show you a bunch
of little techniques that you can use to
really transform a Midi Guitar
instrument and make it sound as
realistic as possible because these
little little tips can go an extremely
long way for getting you a very
realistic result with all midi
instruments so we're going to jump in
and check that out in one second but
before we do I just have a really quick
announcement I am super super excited to
announce that today we are launching our
spring sale for 2024 so from right now
until the end of April 14th you can head
over to our website make poop music.com
we have 25% off of All sample packs
preset packs midi packs courses bundles
and that lasts until the end of April
14th 25% off of absolutely everything
and I have one more really exciting
announcement something I've been holding
off for months that I'm super excited to
talk about and that is that we just
launched our brand new start to finish
production course called producer
principles indie rock and alternative
this course is 16 1 half hours it's 47
different lessons where I show you how
to write produce engineer edit mix and
master and indie rock song similar to
artists such as claro Phoebe Bridges boy
Genius wallow
bleachers all of those kind of indie
rock acts that you know and you love we
produce a song in that style from start
to finish we go over mixing live drums
working with Midi Guitar as well as real
guitar sculpting tones how to record
vocals it is a super super in-depth
course I am super excited that it's
finally out we put so much time and
effort into this one so you can go
enroll in that now that is also 25% off
the course will normally be 250 bucks
but if you get it for the spring sale
you can grab it for $187.50 and you have
lifetime access so go check out that
course go check out producer principles
101 and go check out all of our other
stuff that we have on our website right
now it's at make poop music.com shop the
spring sale before it's over on April
14th all right thanks for bearing with
me with those announcements I was really
excited to get that out of the way now
let's go ahead and let's dive in so the
first thing that I want to talk about
when you are working with Midi Guitar is
that you need to kind of understand how
a Guitar Works right I think this kind
of goes for all midi instruments the
more that you know about an instrument
the more you know about the terminology
and the technique that goes behind
playing it I think the more realistic
results you can get it's like when you
program drums you understand that people
have two hands and two feet and so you
can't program more than that because
it'll just automatically sound unnatural
same thing kind of goes with guitar you
should know the strings so typically a
guitar is six strings sometimes
Acoustics are 12 and then you should
kind of know how those are spaced apart
so typically a string is about five
semitones from the next one down and so
when you are programming guitar parts
just make sure that you don't have a
bunch of overlapping notes that would
typically happen on the same string of a
guitar because it's one of the most
immediate ways to make it sound fake um
other than that there's just a bunch of
little terms that you might want to know
so when I open up an example that I'm
going to show you in a second if you
don't know anything about guitar this
might look overwhelming right so if you
go to their preset browser if you go
down here you might see a bunch of
things called open muted mixed strummed
arpegio riff you're going to see things
like hammer on and pull offs you're
going to see things like pal mute you're
going to see things like doubling if you
don't know anything thing about acoustic
guitar it might be hard for you to go
ahead and just start programming it even
with a really good Library like some of
the Native Instrument stuff or some of
the ample guitar stuff if you don't know
how a guitar is laid out or you know
what palm muting is versus open picking
is or what finger picking sounds like
versus using a a pick or a pluck drum
you're going to have a lot of trouble
dialing in that tone so I think first
and foremost learn a little bit about
guitar even if you can't play guitar
even if you don't have a physical guitar
knowing when to use a neck pickup versus
a bridge pickup or when to use a pick
versus fingers or when to use P mutes
versus open strumming that is 99% of the
battle that I see people have issue with
when they program uh Midi Guitar it just
doesn't sound real because it's not
played like how a guitarist would play
on that song So once you learn those
things then you can kind of start to
dive into libraries you can kind of
start to figure out do you want to use a
library like electric Sunburst that
really runs off of loops and off of
somebody who played a bunch of different
versions of something or do you want to
program your own Melodies so let's go
ahead and let's talk about the
differences of that so here's what our
guitar will start off like when I'm
talking about bad programming bad sound
selection bad Arrangement this is what
it sounds
like so let's go ahead and talk about
the first thing which is just making
sure that you have the right pattern
picked or you have the right instrument
picked so for the first one I want a PM
muted sounding guitar so I'm going to
use the electric Sunburst by session
guitarist and Native Instruments and
then when you're using something like
their guitar plugins it's really easy
for you to go and
sort so you can hear all of those
different patterns they all sound
different they all react differently and
then something like this will have key
[Music]
changes then if you hit something like c
1 you have
muted if you go to D1 you'll have
straightforward
muted so just knowing how the guitar
plugin that you're using is laid out and
how to kind of alternate between
different strumming patterns or
different chord patterns that is huge
when it comes to creating realistic
sounding guitar especially when you're
using something like a library that runs
off of chord generation also you can
take it an extra way if you want to pull
up the auto cord so you could go ahead
and do things like play sus
chords or seventh
chords
take it up an
[Music]
octave things like having that chord
generator in there is really nice to
make sure that you can kind of get
realistic voicings realistic movements
if I'm doing something that is core
generated so you know like pal mutes
like this a big strummy acoustic guitar
I'm almost always reaching for a library
that has those movements baked in
because if I don't it's really really
hard almost impossible to program
something that feels that Dynamic and
has that kind of Bounce With kind of
chord movement so once you have your
guitar sounding exactly like you like it
we have
this one thing that I like to do to
really kind of dial in the sound is I'm
going to go ahead and take all the amps
and effects
off and that gives me something called
guitar di direct input so what I like to
do when I'm programming Midi Guitar is
get di so then I can go ahead and pop my
own tone on because a lot of these
libraries have tones kind of built in I
don't find them as good as I could kind
of dial in on my own so by simply you
know selecting the right pattern knowing
my chord changes and then taking off
that effect we get something that
automatically sounds a little bit more
realistic now I've gone ahead and made a
kind of alternate version of that that
has a tone that I've built from tone
king imperial by neural DSP I like to
use third party uh you know amp vsts
because it's what I would do on a live
guitar and now we have something that
sounds like this
I'll also typically bounce those kind of
core generated guitar files into audio
so I can go ahead and cut them I can
have the accent plugged exactly where I
want
them and if you didn't know any better
you'd probably think that that was a
real guitar so that's just a quick
example of how to take something that
sounds you know like
this and then turn it into something
like
this get rid of these
amps and put something a little bit more
realistic on it so that's what I do when
it comes to like PA muting guitar or
chord guitar I'll typically just try to
find the right sound and then dial it
back dial in my own little uh tone and
then go from there let's go ahead and
let's talk about a guitar
Melody so this is using the electric
mint guitar this is where I'm just going
to play one note at a time time this is
where it really comes in handy knowing
you know where your fingers would fall
on a guitar like for example on a
guitar those two notes are probably not
going to be played at the same time
because you're probably going to play
them on the same string so one way that
you can get around that is by playing
the mono
version but sometimes a mono version
also won't have it feel right if you're
trying to play a lower string so I just
try to be cognizant when I am
programming this of doing something
like
instead of you know if I was playing
piano maybe I leave
[Music]
those like that chord is never going to
happen like that on a guitar you need to
kind of understand guitar voicings when
you're using these kind of single
melodic instruments so now that we have
that again what I like to do is kind of
just take this amp off and then this is
really where I talk about like knowing
what you want with a guitar cuz if I had
something like my Fender strap
I can swap my pickups they sound
drastically
different versus
this versus
this do you want them doubled so they're
wide do you want fret
[Music]
noise do you want the tuning precise or
sloppy sometimes I'll loosen up on the
tuning so it's not so perfect for this I
didn't want double I like it on that
middle pickup I'm going to bring the
noise down just a little bit and then I
don't need this
mic so once I have that tone exactly how
I like it I go from you know having midi
that looks like this where everything is
just 127 velocity everything falls right
on the
grid cuz that's not realistic that's not
how a guitar player would play it and
what I do is I start to humanize things
so as you can see here things are
slightly after or slightly before the
grid uh we don't have you know
everything hitting at the same exact
velocity so now we get
[Music]
this and that just sounds so much more
realistic rather than
[Music]
this then I'll print out that guitar GI
I'll do the same thing where I pop a
tone
on
and then I'll pan it to the side just
like I would with a real guitar so now
we go from having this kind of generic
pal mute and this generic
Melody to feeling a lot more realistic
just by doing you know smart programming
automation dynamic
[Music]
programming and then you kind of just do
the same thing with every guitar layer
let's do one more so you can kind of see
what I'm talking about so let's do like
a guitar pluck maybe like a 1975 you
know nightly style pluck so this one is
just using the electric
vintage so again as you can see this is
all programmed at 127 it's all perfectly
to the grid it just doesn't feel real at
all so first thing that I like to do
again is make this feel a little bit
more real play it like how a guitar
player would so I have Dynamic
velocities and I'm also adding in these
little kind of Ghost Notes
so like up picking and down
[Music]
picking and it just feels a lot more
realistic and a lot more Dynamic than
something like
this now once I do that I've picked the
right instrument I've picked exactly
what I want I don't have a pattern I'm
just playing this muted Melody again if
I play this
open doesn't sound right that's why you
need to know if you need to Pal mute or
if you want to play it open or do you
want to play it with a
finger that's too
soft then we go to our amps don't need
those we go to guitar settings I'm
actually on the both pickups so on uh
any kind of humbucker guitar you have a
bridge and a neck this one's going to
use both go ahead and dial my settings
in print out that Di and then once I
have Di and I pop my own little tone on
there it sounds like this here's the
DI go ahead and add some EQ add my own
little ampim this is just a query Wong
by neural DSP I have some compression
some tube saturation like a tube
screamer basically I have my amp I have
some EQ happening I can play around with
like the cabinet
[Music]
micing I have my chorus my delay my
Reverb and now something that sounds
like this straight off
rip sounds like this it's still the same
exact
instrument but since we did Dynamic you
know programming we have different
velocities everything's not on the grid
we're kind of programming this more like
how a guitarist would play it just goes
a really really really long way so we've
talked a little bit about how to pick
the right pattern
how to you know dial in your di tone
print that out so you can process it
like a live track guitar and how to go
ahead and handle some you know different
picking patterns or like lead patterns
the last thing that I want to cover is
how to actually figure out the voicing
for acoustic guitar so here is an
acoustic that we have this is just the
picked acoustic this is just the Melody
from session guitarist I used all of
these because they came in complete um
so a lot of people will probably have
these and uh here's what it sounds like
if we you know
just play it
[Music]
out it sounds super super fake one thing
that I want to talk about before I show
you how we're going to humanize that uh
midi is I want to actually explain to
you a little bit about guitar voicing
right so if I play an acoustic guitar if
I'm trying to play a C major on piano
typically you'll just play that little
uh you know Triad You'll Play the C the
E and the
g however on an acoustic guitar the way
that the strings are set up you don't
typically voice it like that so on a
guitar what you would probably do is
you'd play the C as the root and then
you probably play that g on the next
string down and then you would probably
go ahead and play something like that
e a little bit higher
up so you can kind of experiment with
that Cubase actually has a really cool
tool called the chord generator or uh in
the chord pads you can actually pick if
you want your voicings to be selected
like a p
piano or like a guitar so if we go to
guitar it spaces out that voicing a
little bit so what I'm doing if I'm kind
of adding in my own strum guitar or I'm
kind of adding in a guitar chord with
midi is I'll swap this to guitar player
just to kind of double check that I am
voicing it like a guitar I know logic
has this feature I'm pretty positive
Ableton has this feature most the aw
should have where you can kind of swap
the voicing between piano and guitar
because again they are so different so
you can pick Triads modern Jazz whatever
you want and then you know once you have
a chord you can change the voicing you
can add
extensions those are all a c chord but
the way that they are voiced is
completely unique to guitar not piano
not synth not violin so when you are
picking your chords if you can have some
kind of chord generator like that it
really helps so that's what I use to
dial in all of these chords right here
and then after I had that midi I thought
it just sounds super unrealistic so what
we're doing is once again we're
humanizing everything with an acoustic
guitar you're never ever ever hitting
multiple strings at the same time you're
always kind of strumming them so that's
exactly the kind of pattern that you
want to
replicate so you see right here how it's
kind of creating a waterfall effect of
you know lowest to highest that's the
same way that you would strum a
guitar and then as you can see right
here these little notes
we just have them a little bit softer so
it feels
like rather than on the original up here
everything's just super
hard listen to that vers is
this so now once we've done that once
we've gotten that midi to feel a little
bit more realistic there's you know
nothing's quantized nothing is super
hard velocities once again we go into
our guitar setting we're going to figure
out what we want for this so there's no
effects on for this guitar I want it
doubled I want the condenser mic instead
of like a dynamic or a ribbon and uh you
can compress the velocities if you want
I have the tuning at like 16% so it
feels decently realistic and then I
print that out typically all of these
kind of acoustic Midi Guitar elements
will be super bright and like super
inyour face so what I always like to do
is just darken them up a little bit with
some EQ sometimes I'll use like tape
saturation I'm going to go ahead and
compress it a little bit because that's
what I would do with acoustic guitar
that I record in the room and then I'm
going to add some kind of like room
response or room impulse or Reverb just
to put that in a live space so I have a
small room at like 20% wet and now it
sounds like
[Music]
this so now we go from
this to this
[Music]
and then when you pop all four of those
guitars on it is a pretty massive effect
of a difference so let's go ahead and
let's just add all the original ampim so
you can hear everything exactly how it
would have been straight out of native
instruments and then I'll show you what
it sounds like with all of my tones and
all of my effects so here's what it
sounds like out of Native
[Music]
Instruments Everything feels super
undynamic non-humanized once we humanize
[Music]
everything once we get rid of all of
those effects and do our own Di and our
own
[Music]
processing and then the last thing that
I like to do if possible is just find
some kind of realistic guitar Loops that
are Live recorded that maybe have some
fret noise they have some sliding they
have something else going on something
like
this
something like
[Music]
this and then once I kind of subtly
layer those in they're not adding
anything super crazy melodically but
they do add a lot of
[Music]
[Applause]
realism and you can follow these same
exact steps in terms of you know
programming your velocity so they feel
more Dynamic making sure everything
doesn't fall right on the grid knowing
how to voice an instrument or how to
actually play that instrument these kind
of things I think scale across
programming all realistic instruments so
bass violin piano it's a little bit
different when you're doing a shum
element like a bass or a guitar or a
boat element like a violin because when
we play it on keyboard it's super
percussive right piano can feel really
realistic really easily sense can feel
really realistic even drums because
drums are percussion and piano is
percussion but strum stuff it is not
like this at all so if you can find
elements or ways to you know think about
a piano more as a guitar or more as a
bass I think it goes a long way so now I
want to show you one final little
example I'm going to show you what
everything sounds like with some really
simple drums and bass in the mix so you
can hear how unrealistic this initial
kind of programed guitar sounds versus
what we come up with at the end so here
we
[Music]
go
humanize
[Music]
it with my
tones and every guitar that you're
hearing there is programmed so hopefully
these tips will help you kind of
understand how to program guitar a
little bit better how to get a little
bit more out of some of the guitar you
know plugins that you might have how to
kind of sculpt your own tones and take
something that feels super generic super
unnatural super undynamic and turn that
into something that feels a little bit
more raw a little bit more authentic and
a little bit more human so hopefully you
enjoyed this again if you want to
support us you can head over to our
website make poop music.com check out
our spring sale that we are running
right now 25% off of literally anything
on our store also make sure that you go
check out that course that I just talked
about Indy Rock and alternative because
this is a thing that kind of do
throughout the course right the course
uses a ton of live guitar and a ton of
live bass but in it I talk a little bit
about how to turn those elements into
midi and then in the course you can kind
of see what it sounds like with live
elements versus midi elements we even go
over things like programming drums to
start the song and then mixing Live
recorded drums towards the end of the
song this thing is incredible I record
my vocals in real time edit everything
in real time it's 16 and 1/2 hours you
get to literally see every decision that
I'll make when I make a record and uh
the final song that came out is is
absolutely incredible so go check that
out indie rock and alternative is
available now again it's 25% off because
of our sale as well and then other than
that I'm going to see you guys next week
with more content let me know what
videos you want to see down in the
comments down below if you like this
make sure you like comment and subscribe
helps us out a ton but I'll see you soon
much love peace